it was crazy it was a little sad i was
not there just more memories without me
guys
spoilers are ahead as we're talking
about the spider-man no way home casts
favorite scenes from the movie there's
so many
i don't know
click away now if you haven't seen it
too late let's go
number one it would be easier to say tom
holland's favorite part of the movie was
the whole movie tom has a few different
favorites for sure he absolutely loved
working with the whole gang his favorite
person to hang out with on set being
alfred molina you love alfred yeah i had
a really good time with alfred but his
favorite scene was actually one with
willem dafoe where dafoe has a speech
about an existential crisis the
monologue in question includes the line
peter you're struggling to have
everything you want while the world
tries to make you choose he gave the
speech 30 times and no two takes were
the same it was chilling holland was
also impressed defoe could snap into
character in a heartbeat and snap out of
it just as quick now his favorite moment
working with benedict cumberbatch that
he found really fun he'd only hinted at
but after peter was punched into the
mirror dimension by strange there's a
moment later on in the sequence that was
a very nice surprise for him any idea
what that was building that whole thing
and fighting him was really cool without
a doubt he says spider-man is the best
thing that's ever happened to me well no
doi he gets to do his dream job it made
him rich and it introduced him to his
extremely talented girlfriend
number two there is one thing tom didn't
like so much though tom holland's least
favorite scene to film was most
definitely one with alfred molina he was
upside down the entire day for 11 hours
being battered by doc ock the blood was
rushing to his head he was in a harness
the director was getting nitpicky so he
was complaining to his brother harry
about it and harry told him to suck it
up tom got his revenge though and got
his brother a tiny role in the movie he
asked the stunt coordinator please just
whatever you do with the stunt make it
so that he's upside down it got so bad
for harry he started forgetting his
lines and his eyes looked like they were
going to pop out of his head harry
admitted it was brutal and the worst
part was they've cut the scene tom's
just not a fan of hanging stunts in
general because it makes you feel like
you're like a toy in a claw machine the
worst part of that you like come to the
floor and you have that like half a
second moment where you go in attention
and every
number three if you know anything about
andrew you could probably guess his
favorite part andrew garfield's favorite
scene involved the superhero whom he
adored as a kid toby is my favorite
right because that's my childhood he
called his favorite bit toby's better
angel moment to be there and witness
that as it was being filmed would have
been like a dream come true for the
middle brother since he'd even dressed
up like maguire's spider-man as a kid
for halloween i get chills thinking
about it even now and a personal
favorite moment for andrew garfield
involving his character was when he was
able to write a wrong after his
franchise got cancelled saving mj saying
that was really beautiful and it kind of
sold me on the whole thing what he
really appreciated about the
storytelling was his and maguire
spider-man were in service to tom
holland's story however their individual
moments of redemption remain his
favorite
number 4. tobey maguire is the most
eloquently spoken of the spider-man it
comes with experience maguire has only
recently started doing press for the
movie but he's already come out to say
what his favorite part was he adored the
coda of the movie coda meaning the end
saying it had such a sweet elegance to
it which we couldn't agree with him more
number five the guy in the chair is
actually a good description for both ned
and jacob jacob battalon really doesn't
like doing stunts he finds them super
uncomfortable the water stuff and the
chaffey harness he does find it cool he
can fall off of something and not worry
about fatally injuring himself though it
seems almost like a very very controlled
ride
number six zendaya's definitely speaking
from personal preference because her
gripe against the movie doesn't sound
like an attack on the storytelling when
you spend time behaving as a character
you root for them but the ending worked
great just not from zendaya's
perspective she really didn't like it
she didn't like that it wasn't a happily
ever after she disliked it so much she
felt like she had to apologize for it
i'm sorry i wanted them to have a happy
ending she just wanted them to be in
love and go off to college is that so
much to ask
number seven shout out to aunt may one
thing zendaya loved about the movie was
aunt may's role in it she thought it was
awesome that mae was raising peter on
her own and people always seemed to
expect peter to have a mentor or father
figure with tony stark and mysterio and
such but aunt may was a great role model
who raised an incredible young man i
feel like she doesn't get the credit she
deserves you're right number eight truly
a proud mama marissa tomei hasn't spoken
out about her favorite scene as far as
we could tell but she does find john
favreau hilarious this is like great to
be able to work opposite him she thinks
his improv skills are fabulous and
generally she's so proud and impressed
by the young cast specifically zendaya
for how driven she is at 25 years old
zendaya is just absolutely
ravishing
number nine jamie foxx's opinions are
personal he also adored willem dafoe's
performance we've just been watching
willam and it seems personal he
proceeded to compare the two's
characters and goals where elektro has a
vendetta against the whole world the
goblins only got his eyes on one man or
maybe three
number 10. spoken like a true thespian
for benedict cumberbatch the thing that
gets him excited is the moment when
peter parker comes to doctor strange for
help because the development of this
scene comes from them working on a team
in the avengers movies as equals strange
doesn't take into account peter is still
a high schooler and this all comes down
to his favorite thing being the
relationship between the characters with
tom and i that's that's a really
beautiful relationship that's kicking
off number 11. willem dafoe knows what
he wants and he goes after it for willem
the scenes where he got to do his own
stunts were his favorite he had a few
requirements before signing on to do the
role he didn't just want a cameo to do
this physical stuff
was important to me he wanted to do the
actions too because all of that informs
your relationship to the story it makes
you earn your right to play the
character in a funny way and he really
admired director john watts because he
would get the incredibly specific shot
he was looking for but would always give
the actors opportunities to play or try
something new after he got the shot he
needed
number 12. alfred molina was on a
journey of reinventing himself he adores
working with jamie foxx for his improv
and tom holland because he has such a
strong grasp of the tone after playing
the character for so long molina also
loved putting the initial work into
returning to a character he hadn't
played in 17 years he re-watched sam
raimi spider-man 2 to refine the
character but also had to find a balance
between how he played doc ock then and
how he wanted to approach him in a
universe completely different from his
own and bring a fresh take to the
character because it would be boring to
do the same thing twice old but new
familiar but different it's a wonderful
place to be the cast absolutely adored
their time working together on no way
home and that was reflected on screen
from their incredible improv skills to
their deep bond as a cast to their
genuine love of the plot as actors and
fans it's no wonder this movie was such
a success what was your favorite moment
from no way home let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching